two parallel lines say like LNM and you
have an image over here let's call this
the preimage before what we're gonna do
is we're going to reflect it over line L
and then we're going to reflect it over
line M okay so when you do a reflection
what you want to do is you want to
measure the perpendicular distance to
that line or reflection and you want to
go the same distance okay on the other
side of that line so you're you're
folding it over the line but you want to
think about going perpendicular in the
same distance so if I do that I'm just
kind of drawing this freehand but I just
want to show you what you can see here
is originally this flag was pointing to
the left right when we reflect it now
it's pointing to the right okay and if
we reflect it a second time okay so
again look at this distance here we want
to go the same distance perpendicular to
the line of reflection you can see we're
getting a flag that looks something like
this now you can see again it's pointing
back to the left so what ends up
happening is this preimage we'll just
call this a we'll call this one a prime
we'll call this one a double Prime what
is happening is you reflect it and you
reflect it again now it's in the same
orientation as it was originally but
what happened is the figure actually
slid it actually translated okay from
here to here now the question that
sometimes will ask you in your class in
your geometry class is how far does it
slide or does it translate from a to a
double Prime
and what you're interested in is you're
interested in this distance between the
two parallel lines of course the
perpendicular distance let's just say
that this is a two inches well then what
would happen is the figure would
actually slide double so it actually
would be a translation of four inches so
that's the key
so composition of reflections ends up
being a translation or a slide however
you want to say it and it ends up
sliding double the distance okay between
the two parallel lines